robert spencer should the motion picture
academy have allowed will smith
to accept his best act reward after he
smacked chris rock in the face
and should there be a consequence when
the board finally issues their ruling on
the event well you know insane
motion picture academy there would be
consequences but this is the motion
picture academy that has allowed all
manner of people of incredible low
incredibly low moral standards to
win awards and to be lionized and
celebrated i mean look at harvey
weinstein's career and so on you know
next to harvey will smith just doesn't
look as is as terrible but i do think
that the real consequence of this could
be
people slapping people who they don't
like
in public places all over the place and
comedians especially to start with but
not only them stephen colbert even
called for biden to slap peter ducey for
asking him questions he didn't like so
it's just more of the decline of
civility in the united states that we've
seen in the last few years